hello everybody and so today I want to
I'm gonna make a few videos that are
going to discuss the acceleration of
time and how we have most of us
experienced it that in the modern world
time seems to speed up as no more
technology develops the more all these
new media technology develops the more
it feels like time is accelerating and
so there's a way to understand that and
I'm gonna start this video and talk a
bit about the principle of that and then
maybe in a few other videos that might
talk about other systems like credit
which really interest me so here we go
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so one of the staples of the modern
world is this sense this feeling that
time accelerating now it's interesting
because we really need to step into a
phenomena phenomenological point of view
in order to understand that because the
scientists you know the the materialists
will tell you that of course no times a
constant you know time I doesn't
actually accelerate but in the human
experience time it doesn't exist that
way time works in these it is is
compressible and is also expandable and
in our experience we've all experienced
moments where a minute lasts
phenomenologically lasts you know feels
like it lasted an hour even when then
we've also experienced how you know
something will just snap by and we feel
like no time has gone by at all and so
in terms of society one of the
phenomenons that we've seen in the
modern world is this acceleration of
time everything is moving faster we see
people running around we see people who
have no time people who are always
pressed people who are always rushing
and this is a side effect of modernity
in general there are many factors which
feed into this experience and this
reality one of one of them is of course
in general this this technology
technology speeds up time now why is it
why does it speed up time so you have to
understand the world I've given you this
model before but the best way to
understand it is to understand the world
as a wheel ok and in the middle of the
wheel is the something invisible like
our identity like like a name like you
know the spiritual aspects which bring
us together that which makes us anything
one we could call the center of the
wheel and so as you move out from that
Center you know as you move out you have
to
and these layers around you in order to
help you to move further and further
away and so you could understand it in
terms of technology I've talked about
this in terms of what's called the
garments of skin this notion that as a
human person there are certain limited
things you can do and then when you add
technologies to you what it does is it
makes you more powerful it makes you
able to move further away from what you
would usually be able to do okay it
moves you away from that but then it
also makes you dependent on those
technologies and so as you are able to
as you add technologies and you are able
to move further and further away from
what you usually would do you can
accomplish more in in a shorter amount
of time right and so if I just have a
rock and I have to bang nails into a
into my house it's gonna take forever
but if I have a nail gun I could just
you know I could knock those nails in in
just in a few minutes and so what's
funny about it is that we usually use
the word to save time but it actually
that is not what ends up happening we
don't actually end up saving time would
we end up happening is compressing or
let's say we end up accelerating our
existence and then we end up doing more
than we would if we were so imagine you
take would take you a full day to hammer
in some nails with a hammer but then if
I have a nail gun I just can do it in a
few minutes and don't what it ends up
doing is it ends up time ends up
replacing the times that ends up
replacing space you could say or time
ends up eating away at normal space
because it compresses it it like pushes
space together
now when I talk about the nail gun and
the nails it's a little bit harder to
understand but if I talk it's there but
it's harder to picture but if I talk
about something like transportation
and of course it's quite easy to see
what we've seen for example what modern
transportation has done to space is that
it has it has almost destroyed space it
has destroyed coherent space now the car
for example we the more now the way we
understand even the way we understand
distance we always we understand
distance in terms of time you know we
calculate distance in terms of how long
does it take you know how many
kilometers an hour can I cover or how
many miles an hour can I cover it sorry
I'm Canadian how many miles an hour can
I cover in you know in order to reach
somewhere else and so the distance that
a place has is calculated in time right
we calculated how much time is covered
and what happened with the automobile is
that we'd compress time we're pushing
time we're compress space all right
we're pushing space together and so in
order to reach somewhere which before it
would take me several days journey now
takes me a few hours and so I'm where
we're making time we're eating away at
space where we're eating away at space
we're making space disappear we're
slowly eroding at normal space and this
is happening in the way it's part of the
way I've told you this before the part
the way that cities are set up the way
that we set up our societies are now
totally based on this transportation and
so instead of having a concentric city
model with you know a a church and a
town center with a bank and you know the
you know the the market and the
government building and then you have
houses and businesses around that you
know they kind of layer out into this
this is concentric this concentric model
of stable space instead we fragment we
have fragmented our space and so we we
we take our car and we can drive for 20
minutes to go to a restaurant then you
take our car you could drive 20 minutes
to go to you know half an hour or 45
minutes to go to your work you do that
and so what happens is you we have let's
say massive shopping malls that that are
just this one blip
on a map and you know it's this huge
huge shopping mall which is meant to
serve people that are miles and miles
and miles away and then you have the
same with houses and houses spread up
across the land and so it's what's
happening is it's compressing it's
compressing our capacity to inhabit
space you could say and so definitely we
see it in transportation but we see it
even more in terms of the new
technologies the internet the the
Internet is really a transportation
method the Internet
what it does is it makes space disappear
and so everything has become time in the
internet everything has become time all
these servers that are all over the
world we don't even know where the
information goes through we don't even
know what you know what it takes in
terms of this this kind of hidden secret
network underneath to make our
experience of immediacy happen and so
with the internet and and the telephone
all the communications tell technologies
but the internet most of all you know it
connects us with people that are all
over the map and so the map ceases to
exist everything becomes how how then
we've actually reduced that to zero
right we've reduced the with the time
with these communication systems we've
reduced the time the space to absolute
zero so there's an immediacy where I can
be in contact with people from all over
the world at the at the same time and
everybody can be there and be you know
let's say in communication with me from
all these different places and we can
access information from everywhere in
simultaneity right and so the ultimate
the ultimate result of that is you could
call it the destruction of time that
time that I keep sorry I keep using the
wrong word the destruction of space
space gets eroded gets eroded gets
eroded and gets turned into this strange
simultaneous point in in in time where
every
this is weird simultaneous pointed space
where time is the only factor which
links me to all over the the planet okay
and so it is it's very odd because it
actually this speeding up of time is
actually a destructive force it it is
really like a dragon on the edge of
space which is slowly devouring
devouring devouring the space and soon
you just have this whirlwind of motion
this whirlwind of time which is spinning
and spinning and spinning and it's
dizzying and we can all experience that
dizzying as we live in our in these
frenetic times and this kind of frenetic
motion of experience and so it's
difficult to think about this stuff and
so maybe some of you will think that
it's not totally clear and it has to be
honest it's this stuff that I'm still
kind of working on and I'm still trying
to fully it once you start to think
about it too much your brain your brain
starts to your brain starts to fry
there's an interesting thing also that's
that that happens like this interplay
between time and space in the modern
world is very particular because let's
say in ancient times there used to be
two modes of being you could say there
used to be sedentary mode where you know
someone would inhabit the land and then
would exist in space would inhabit the
land it would would then witness time
you could say could call it like that
and so you you live in a place and you
look at you know the stars move and you
see the Sun move and you see the cycles
around you and there's another mode of
living which we could be called nomadic
existence which is which was kind of
like the weird opposite where you
actually traveled through through space
but you inhabited time so there's two
modes of being or very fundamental in
fact you find them right there at the
beginning of the Bible in the story of
Cain and Abel where you have the
cain who is an agriculturist and you
have abel who is a is a nomad who you
know who's a pastoral figure and so
those two modes of being they kind of
they tend to balance each other out and
what's very odd is in the modern world
we have eliminated the nomadic lifestyle
there they're barely there are no really
nomadic tribes anymore maybe you know a
little bit the gypsies and maybe in
Africa a few a few nomadic tribes like
them you know like the the Touareg or
maybe the the Masai a few tribes like
that that are nomadic but they're very
few in and they're very compressed
because we we want we want to we want to
delimit everything you know the world
has these very clear borders everything
has been completely manifest you know
there's no there's no place in the world
which is vague and it which is not
totally defined and so I think that's
also part of this strange idea that this
strange idea that somehow we are now
being how can I say this that we inhabit
these this space but we can see time is
accelerating around us and then also
space is being compressed into is being
compressed into time it's very odd it's
it's very difficult to understand
because even when you think about it it
kind of flips in your mind but hopefully
that'll be food for thought and what I'm
hoping to do is because now I've been
trying to figure this stuff out for a
long time I've been trying to figure
this stuff out for years in fact and so
hopefully you know I was really excited
about a lot of your comments on my
merlin video a lot of people had some
good ideas about the let's say symbolic
challenge that I posed all posed to all
of you and so I would I would ask all
you two to get on board again and to
think about time and space and to think
about this strange acceleration of time
that we're going through because one of
the things that technology does is that
technology is on the edge right so you
you add these layers as you move forward
and there's also this notion that as you
move out right as you move out from your
Center you're also moving out into the
future and so there's a sense in which
the potentiality that's on the outside
of the of this ring that I'm then I try
to describe the world as is also the
potentiality of the future and so as
technology increases as technology
accelerates it's also as if the future
is coming at you faster and so you you
this the the experience of the future is
accelerating right and you see it in
technology all the times like you know
these technologies that succeed each
other succeed each others to see each
other and everything is speeding up in
terms of technology but for some strange
reason it does that also to our
existence itself not just the technology
but as we engage in that mode of being
which is this constant taking from
potentiality this adding layers upon
layers upon layers and we just do it
faster and faster and faster that what
happening is our experience of time is
also changing and the world is
accelerating around us and it seems to
be something that we can't totally
control it seems to be something which
is part of this cosmic experience like a
cosmic cycle that we're going through
but I think that it's probably good to
be aware of it in order to be able to
mitigate the consequences on our psyche
because obviously I think that diseases
like ADHD you know those types of
diseases attention deficit and
hyperactivity all those diseases which
suddenly had popped up in our society
which never existed before are part of
the problem right the notion that you
would have attention deficit that your
attention cannot focus on one thing for
a long time but that you're constantly
shifting your attention to the to
something which is coming on the horizon
seems to be a good way to describe our
society as a whole as we move forward
and forward into new technologies and
into this constant change of
beards and we also expect that to be
happening in terms of everything we
expect things to change in terms of our
morality in terms of our social
structures in terms of you know a lot of
the social justice stuff has to do with
this idea that somehow this change and
this breakdown of stable identities you
know of of stable gender identities is
part of the deal but you can see here
you can actually see time destroying
space when you think of how this notion
that we need to change we need to adapt
to these new gender realities gender is
multiplying in an infinite amount and
this this constant change this fluidity
this gender fluidity is devouring the
the identities of which their their
dependent right of which what they're
talking about and this is happening not
only in terms of gender but it's also
happen in terms of the family in terms
of these broken relationships of people
rate of divorce of the massive rate of
divorce and then you know people getting
back together again and so you have
these these these splintered identities
as people desire changes people want to
change their relationship it ends up
splintering our identities and having
you know you have your your your mother
and then your stepfather and then then
you have your father and her girlfriend
and then they break up again and then it
it creates this massive this massive
chaos of relationships as we desire and
as we we are in a world that sees change
as a mode of existing in itself and so
hopefully that that is something that is
now that will give you food for thought
and I think my next video is going to be
about the economic system and about
credit and how credit participates in
this system of accelerating time and and
the breakdown of identity and space for
those who are interested a lot of this
stuff is that the basics of this stuff
let's say the structure of this is
covered in my brother's book I've told
you many times the language of creation
so check it out if you're interested in
getting a sense of this notion of a
relationship between time and space I
think it'd be quite worthy I want to
give you a little bit of news in terms
of my own experience
for those who made it this far in the
video you know Mark Hart family for the
first time two days ago we had a
sit-down meal just our family it was the
first time in three weeks that we have
been able to do that we are in this
rental house that we are going to stay
in for a few months because everything
is still unclear in terms of the
government in terms of the new
regulations with the dike whether or not
it's going to change places we know that
some areas are going to be not
inhabitable anymore that we're just
going to destroy the houses and people
are going to have to find other places
we don't know where that is we we're
pretty sure that our house isn't going
to be part of that but we are definitely
not going to make any decision and go
back into our house or you know we need
to rebuild it rebuild the basement and
even even the first floor was wrecked as
well because we had to we had to go
downstairs and we kind of wrecked the
floor we have to redo we have to redo
stuff so we're not going to we're not
going to do that until we have the
proper information so for now we're kind
of in this in-between state which is
probably why I'm thinking about this
breakdown of identity you know chaos
chaos world and so hopefully we can get
something fruitful out of it and it'll
be helpful last thing too in the next on
the on this Saturday know this Sunday
and next Monday I forget what the day is
I put it in the description the exact
date I will be in Trevor port Louisiana
I will give two talks one on the Sunday
one on the Monday the talks will be
about one will be about the shape of
paradise to the human heart and it will
be will be trying to relate the
cosmology with the personal experience
and the other will be about how funny is
the end of the world living in a world
of the margin and so talking about the
craziness of our world marginalia
and monsters and all that great stuff
and so if you are in the area it would
be great to have you check out check out
the details in the descriptions those
will be the clearest ones and hope to
see there everybody that has been giving
giving money to us in terms of the flood
stuff I'm eternally grateful I it has
been such a it has brought such peace of
mind to my family to be able to be you
to rent this house while we're waiting a
lot of the other families are are having
to camp out you know they they borrow
campers and are on their yard and
they're just kind of waiting for the
government to decide and it's a it's
pretty sad desolate situation and so
because we have all these people that
care for us and then if they wanted to
help us we rarely be able to be here at
the family and try to restart our life
as much as possible so so hopefully I'll
be able to get some videos to you pretty
soon and thanks again for sticking
around and yeah all right see everybody
soon bye